we are going to be live reacting to
yugioh the abridged series and other
abridged series aren't which so make
sure to follow us on twitch and make
sure to follow us on other social media
like Twitter Instagram and our discord
links in the description so you can keep
up to date
[Music]
what's up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today I'm back with a highly
requested video I said that I would do
another four kids video if we got 1000
likes on 10 more ways for kids change
one piece and we're well over 2,000
likes at this point so it's about time
this video came out in both ten ways for
kids change one piece and in ten more
ways for kids one piece I asked for you
guys to recommend what other anime you
would like me to look at next and a lot
of you requested yugioh so we're doing
it if you want to see more content like
this smash that like button and don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you know the second
we come out with a new vid if we can get
over 1000 likes on this video we can
either do a part 2 or take a close look
at another anime for kids censored let
me know what you want to see in the
comments below I want you guys to keep
in mind I'm not here to be the millionth
guide to roasts or hate on for kids I
just want to point out some differences
that I think you might find interesting
because I definitely did I'm curious
about what for kids felt they needed to
censor and about how they went about
censoring it if you want to send four
kids to the Shadow Realm more on that
later then that's cool let me know in
the comments but to be honest I enjoyed
watching you you as a kid and even
playing the card game with my friends
poor kids introduced me to you Bo and I
liked it a lot but nonetheless they made
significant changes and sometimes
hilarious ones that we need to go over
in this video now without further ado
it's time to number one the theme song
as you probably know for kids loves to
change the theme songs for the anime day
license and bring to an American market
in the one-piece video we talked about
the one piece rap intro and how some
people loved it and some people were
upset it wasn't even remotely close to
the original here we have a similar
situation the original yugioh song is
nothing like the for kids version the
original is a J pop song and take a
listen
[Music]
Barry
to be honest I had never even heard of
this version until I started doing the
research for this video
now here's the forças version that I'm
sure we're all familiar with
[Music]
let me know which one you guys prefer in
the comments you can find the full ones
on YouTube I personally like the for
kids dub and that probably has a lot to
do with the fact that I heard it first
and it's nostalgic for me however I also
appreciate the fact that it isn't a
cheesy rap it doesn't have a lot of
lyrics but that's what I like about it I
like the background music and the
repetition of and the famous it's time
to do a moment that had us all singing
along to it it also gives you a sense of
the Pharaohs Egyptian origins which is a
nice touch
overall I can't hate on this change but
let me know what you think number two
the name changes so we briefly mentioned
some name changes in one piece like
smoker to chaser but that's nothing
compared to the changes that Fork is
made in uu for kids took most of the
original Japanese names and gave the
characters English names instead here
are some examples Joseph aka Joey
wheeler is actually named Katsuya Joe
new Ichi in the Japanese version his
sister serenity is named Shizuka Tristan
Taylor is named hero to Honda Tia
Gardner is actually on zoom' Misaki
Yogi's grandfather's name Solomon was
originally sugah Roku and I think you
get the point
but I'll also mention that Maximillion
Pegasus was originally Pegasus J
Crawford which I thought was pretty
interesting luckily some names like
Yugi's and seto kaiba's were left the
same or else we might have been calling
the show Johnny O right now number three
the invisible guns now in the one-piece
world guns are more prevalent because
they're dealing with pirates after all
and not a card game albeit a pretty epic
card game but still as you'd expect guns
don't pop up as much in yugioh as they
do in one piece so we don't see some of
the bizarre changes that we see in one
piece in yu-gi-oh for kids simply takes
out the guns rather than making them
water guns rubber hammers cork guns or
shovels although that would have been
insanely funny if Pegasus men were
playing shovels or water guns like Kaiba
in yugioh the guns are replaced with
pointing fingers most of the time which
nonetheless leads to some confusing and
hilarious situations for example we have
Kaiba jumping out of a window
risking his life to escape pointing
fingers we also miss out on this epic
moment where Kaiba stops a gun with a
playing card in another instance bandit
Keith makes it all the way to Pegasus a
seat just the pointer finger Adam which
for some reason justifies Pegasus
sending him down a deadly trap door I
could go on but you get the idea not
only is the gravity of the scene lesson
by removing guns it often leads to weird
situations which don't really make sense
giving the circumstances but it's
probably still better than water guns
number four the violence like with guns
for kid censored violence often they cut
out some particularly violent shots for
instance this includes shots where you
actually see a punch being thrown
I guess they felt they could pretend
that the characters weren't actually
being beaten up if no punches were
actually shown sometimes they pretended
that the punch was just shoving for
example when Joey and Tristan get into
an argument
Joey punches Tristan and forcas tries to
turn into a shove even though you
clearly see that Tristan's face has been
punched or else that's a weird place to
shove someone for kids also took out the
actual punching sound effects but
despite all this it was pretty clear
what was happening most of the time they
also didn't want to show an American
adult beating up children over a card
game so they tried to lighten the mood
in their signature for kids style number
5 the religion for kids for whatever
reason went out of their way to avoid
anything that could be construed as
religious this is what led them to
change miss merry Christmas's name to
miss grant Hogg stay in one piece in
yugioh pentagrams are censored out
whenever they appear in the original
like on the Exodia card or during
battles during the night before Pegasus
is semi-final Yugi has a nightmare and
sees playing cards that contain the
souls of his grandpa kaiba and mokuba
hanging on three crosses Fork has
changed the crosses into pillars instead
similarly when the characters beat Kaiba
or the Dark Magician are hanging on
stones that resemble crosses for kids
change the shape of the stone
cards are also censored by removing
stuff like crosses and halos number six
yugioh season zero here's an interesting
one that I also didn't know about before
I started to do research for this video
there was actually a yu-gi-oh anime that
came out before you guild duel monsters
which we just referred to as yugioh this
anime shows how you you first put
together the Millennium Puzzle and how
he became friends with Joey and Tristan
often in yugioh duel monsters we get
flashbacks to stuff that happen in this
anime however there are significant
differences between the two shows in
this version kaiba has green hair for
instance no joke and there is a main
character called Miho who Tristan is
absolutely infatuated with despite the
fact that she's extremely materialistic
and straight-up annoying the tone of the
show is also considerably darker
although there are some episodes that
deal with duel monsters most deal with
different games that yami-yugi plays
with various people usually criminals
after Yami Yugi wins he uses his power
to torture his opponents psychologically
leading them to go crazy for example he
makes one guy think he's on fire
in yugioh duel monsters we also have
yami-yugi mine crushing people and they
might also be experiencing similar
nightmares in their minds because of it
but that usually isn't shown on screen
number 7 the suggestive content not very
surprising but for kids these sexualizes
everything cards are censored so that
they're wearing less revealing clothes
Mize and Tears clothes are also censored
at times dialog is also censored for
example when Rex is talking to my
originally my son shall do anything that
he wants if he beats her in a duel but
the reward is changed to a simple kiss
in the duct later when Joey is dueling
Rex in the original my says that Rex has
to be Joey to get his reward Joey is
curious about the reward and gets
jealous however in the 4kids version my
just says that he has to be Joey if he
wants to duel her and Joey gets upset
not out of jealousy but because Rex
calls him a Dueling monkey
nice one Rex another notable instances
when taya is going to take a shower and
hear something my rushes in
make sure everything is okay and that's
the end of the forças version in the
original Joey and Tristan are trying to
get a peek at undressed TIA
while Yugi is trying to hold them back
any instances like this one that
suggests that the guys may be interested
in the female body are pretty much taken
out of the for kids version number 8 for
kids voices and dialogue know for kids
anime is complete without a Brooklyn
accent and Joey wheeler fills in that
role in uu yummy Yugi's voice is not
just more confident it is also much much
deeper than regular Ubese Tristan sounds
like Barney the Dinosaur for a few
episodes and that undergoes a voice
change let me know what you think of the
voices in you you like I said I watched
this version of you go first so for me
the voices don't really bother me except
maybe Barney's voice however it is the
creative license that for kids exercises
with the dialogue that really stands out
to me of course
they bring in their bad puns like when
Kaiba's supposed ghosts keep saying you
don't stand a ghost of a chance there's
also the time where they decided to make
the brothers para and DOX rhyme and then
you enjoy get into it this is not
surprising though since you can expect
that if four kids gets their hands on an
anime they will inject into it all of
the puns and corny jokes that they
possibly can
number nine Shadow Realm this might blow
your mind if you didn't know this
already but the Shadow Realm was pretty
much made up by four kids
it's a limbo place of suffering where a
character is sent when in the original
they would have died or been seriously
injured it's a way for for kids to avoid
death but the question is whether it is
really an improvement is a limbo space
of eternal suffering really preferable
to death probably not but I guess if
someone is in the Shadow Realm they are
not technically
that and as a result there is the
possibility as small as it may be that
they might come back to the real world
which is good enough for four kids
Yugi mine crushes aka appears to kill
the clown who pretends to be Kyle's
ghost after their duel in the four kids
dub they made this clown Kaiba's evil
side that the Pharaoh banished her
shadow round after his first duel with
Kaiba
by making him Kaiba's evil side instead
of his own person forecast shows that
people can come back from the Shadow
Realm and that Yugi banishing him there
is not that big of a deal because he's
not actually a person but pure evil
--mess another notable time when the
Shadow Realm is used is when Yugi is
dueling Arcana the two are trapped and
the situation is set up so that the
first person to reach zero Life Points
will have their legs cut off by buzzsaws
by the way that is exactly what happens
when you go meets the sovereign tries
anyways fork has decided to change the
bus sauce to dark energy discs instead
and when they touch you you are sent to
the Shadow Realm in another instance
when Yugi and Kaiba are dueling Lumis
and Umbra in the original Japanese
hitting zero Life Points will mean a
bomb detonating sending the loser
falling through the glass ceiling and to
his death in the for kids version there
is no risk of dying but instead a risk
of falling into the Shadow Realm
although it can be said that the
duelists enter a kind of shadow realm
when they are participating in a shadow
game like when Pegasus dueled Yugi and
regular Yugi had trouble breathing poor
kids took the cause up to the Shadow
Realm and applied it to any
life-threatening situation and now we
move on to number 10 random changes in
this category we're gonna be looking at
some random changes that four kids made
that are kind of puzzling for instance
when Yugi and his friends are on the
ship heading to Pegasus tournament Tia
needs to go to the bathroom
Tristan makes a joke point to the edge
of the boat and telling her to relieve
herself over there she gets angry
telling him she's not a boy meaning she
can't just do it off the side of a boat
for some reason for kids decided that
they can't have taya needing to go to
the bathroom so she just says she's cold
and can't stay still then Tristan laughs
and says randomly
a few hours the Sun will rise and tear
gets mad and says that's not funny so
it's implied that Tristan was making a
joke by saying the Sun will rise another
few hours why this should upset taya so
much is the Millennium Puzzle that is
left for the audience to solve another
random and surprising change was the
fact that forcus took out Yugi's mom
from the anime in episode 50 she
overhears him talking to Yahoo Yugi but
for whatever reason this part is taking
out of the forças anime and there it is
guys ten ways for kids changed yu-gi-oh
thank you so much for watching till the
end and I hope you like this video let
me know if I missed any important
changes and I might include those
changes in part two because there are
definitely too many to jam into one
video where there are any changes that
surprised you and tell me what you
thought of the way for kids handled the
anime in general also type in in another
few hours the Sun will rise in the
comments section to show you're a baller
and that you made it this far if you
haven't already be sure to subscribe for
more videos like this one and smash that
like button if we can get over 1000
likes like we got twice before I'll do
another four kids video once again
thanks so much for watching and until
next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]